[Música]
costa rica- elige a su nuevo presidente
más de 35 millones de personas están
llamadas a escoger entre 25 candidatos
aunque ninguno de los aspirantes
tendrían la votación suficiente para
ganar en primera vuelta que hace menos
de una semana el porcentaje de indecisos
superaba el 30 por ciento
al menos diez personas han muerto en
madagascar por el sillón bats ira y el
fenómeno derrumbó varias edificaciones
en la isla del océano índico en el
pueblo más afectado destruyó el 95 por
ciento de la infraestructura se estima
que más de 40 mil personas han sido
desplazadas en todo el país
nueva crisis política en túnez el
presidente de caixa y disolvió al órgano
independiente encargado del control
judicial al acusarlo de nombrar jueces
corruptos y manipular investigaciones el
máximo juez del país calificó la medida
como ilegal
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
placer acompañarlos empezamos a esta
emisión en costa rica porque el país
centroamericano fue a las urnas para
elegir presidente dos vicepresidentes y
a los 57 diputados de la asamblea
legislativa el voto se dividió entre los
25 aspirantes presidenciales que hay por
lo que se estima que haya una segunda
vuelta el 2 de abril además la variedad
contribuyó a que más del 30 por ciento
del padrón electoral no supiera hace una
semana por quién iba a votar esta noche
se conocerán los resultados y a partir
de las 9 30 de la noche en ahora bogotá
quito lima les contaremos todo en la
jornada en nuestro especial sobre las
elecciones costarricenses
en la amazonía de colombia hay alerta
roja por los incendios forestales que
llevan más de 10 días y que han
consumido cerca de 15 mil hectáreas las
llamas incluso han devorado más de 2.000
hectáreas del parque nacional natural
serranía de chiribiquete que es la selva
húmeda tropical más grande del mundo
hablamos a esta hora con sandra billard
y ella es integrante del comité de
asesor del foro nacional ambiental y
directora de parques nacionales como
vamos señor hablar de bienvenida a
france 24 hay algún indicio que se
conozca de cómo comenzaron estos
incendios y cuál es el panorama en este
momento muchas gracias por la invitación
efectivamente esta es una zona en la que
para esta temporada del año tenemos una
frecuencia de actividad de que más por
el efecto secante de los vientos alisios
y adicionalmente a esto estamos al
frente de un proceso criminal muy
importante de ampliación de la frontera
agropecuaria en la zona norte del
amazonas' que es la parte de lakers que
le corresponde a colombia
lamentablemente a pesar de las acciones
y de las de las buenas intenciones del
gobierno colombiano las acciones
criminales el poder económico y político
que hay de de esta magnitud del trabajo
que implica llegar a estas zonas
boscosas para talar y quemar se está
viendo desbordadas las acciones del
gobierno colombiano es muy grave estamos
teniendo un dato historias hace 10 años
por lo menos no teníamos el nivel de
incendios que están generando la
deforestación en la zona norte y esto
está implicando no solamente la pérdida
de biodiversidad en una de las zonas más
importantes de conexión entre los antes
y la amazona sino que además todo este
material orgánico particulado está
generando ya problemas muy importantes
de calidad de aire en baja de las
ciudades asociadas a la cordillera
oriental colombiana incluido bogotá y ya
en el valle que llega a ciudades como
medellín armenia o pereyra y usted
mencionó brevemente las intenciones del
gobierno de parar esto y una de ellas es
la estrategia artemisa por la que la
fuerza pública combate la deforestación
sin embargo la deforestación
precisamente se ha extendido dentro del
parque chiribiquete qué tan grave está
en este momento esa zona del país
es muy grave y yo quiero hacer una
claridad no solamente en chiribiquete en
esta zona tenemos aproximadamente 6
áreas del sistema nacional de parques
nacionales tenemos en la cordillera la
cordillera de picachos tiene igual la
sierra nevada de la sierra de la
macarena chiribiquete la playa y nuca
que todos estos parques están viendo
afectados por la deforestación el parque
más grave se está viendo afectado es el
parque nacional tiene un parque más
pequeño que chiribiquete sí pero que ha
perdido una gran cantidad de bosque en
este momento entonces la afectación es
muy grande artemisa lamentablemente no
está logran estar detrás de los
determinadores de estas acciones
criminales y está muy asociado el tema
no solamente de aprovechamiento forestal
sino también de ganadería y otros
cultivos más legales señora sandra
aguilar di gracias por estar con
nosotros y pasamos a otras noticias
porque el ciclón bats irá y dejó al
menos 10 personas muertas en madagascar
según las últimas informaciones la
oficina de gestión de desastres del país
informó que unas 47 mil personas fueron
desplazadas a pesar de que el fenómeno
meteorológico se aleja de la nación
africana las lluvias y las inundaciones
rafael pérez nos cuenta los detalles
destrucción y un total de fallecidos aún
sin confirmar este es el panorama que
deja el ciclón bats irá a su paso por
madagascar mientras el fenómeno
meteorológico se aleja se empiezan a
contabilizar los daños la ciudad de
manager y por donde la tormenta tocó
tierra quedó destruida
aquí casi el 95% de la ciudad ha sido
destruida por no decir el 100% como
podemos ver ahora la carretera está
cortada el mar ha subido imploramos al
estado que venga a ayudarnos lo antes
posible la oficina de gestión de
desastres del país informó que no tenían
el número exacto de fallecidos al tiempo
que daba a conocer que unas 47 mil
personas fueron desplazadas a pesar de
que el ciclón vacila y se aleja
persisten las lluvias y las inundaciones
me sobra nadie manche nuria hi stone
fuck tha gracias a dios aquí no se han
reportado fallecidos pero como
representante oficial de este barrio
puedo decir que el daño es grave el
viento era muy fuerte y aunque la gente
tuvo cuidado de proteger sus
pertenencias ha habido muchos daños
de la mañana el agua subió y todo el
barrio quedó bajo el agua antes del paso
de basura y madagascar se recuperaba de
los daños causados por el ciclón
tropical ana que dejó al menos unas 55
personas muertas a causa de los
derrumbes inundaciones y
desprendimientos de tierra que provocó
en su recorrido
el presidente de tunecino caixa y
decidió este domingo disolver el consejo
superior de la magistratura que es el
órgano independiente encargado de
nombrar a los jueces este es el último
episodio de las tensiones políticas en
el país norteafricano desde que el
mandatario suspendió el parlamento el 25
de julio y destituyó al primer ministro
hashim thaci veamos más en este informe
un órgano que ya pertenece al pasado así
se expresó al presidente tunecino caixes
ayer al anunciar su decisión de disolver
el consejo superior de la magistratura
vamos a trabajar en una ley o decreto
temporal para el consejo superior de la
magistratura y este consejo en sí es una
cosa del pasado a partir de ahora
highside acusa al órgano de corrupción y
de ralentizar los procedimientos en las
investigaciones sobre los asesinatos de
prominentes activistas de izquierda como
el militante suscribe light fallecido en
el 2013
lamentablemente algunos jueces de los
tribunales han manipulado el caso de
hecho criba light no es el primer juicio
en el que se intenta ocultar la verdad
durante años el presidente del consejo
judicial denunció la decisión del jefe
de estado y la tachó de ilegal analistas
políticos afirman por su parte que con
esta resolución caixa site apunta al
partido en nada que ha controlado el
parlamento y varios gobiernos desde la
revolución de 2011 y la caída del
dictador ben alí
sayeh tiene en sus manos todo el poder
desde el 25 de julio cuando destituyó a
su primer ministro y suspendió al
parlamento una medida calificada de
golpe de estado por en nada y otros
opositores
algunas figuras políticas y grupos de
derechos humanos han advertido de un
deslizamiento hacia el autoritarismo y
los líderes mundiales han expresado su
preocupación
sin embargo muchos tunecinos acogieron
con satisfacción las medidas del
mandatario contra un sistema político
calificado de corrupto el presidente
francés emmanuel majo me habló
telefónicamente con su homólogo
estadounidense joe biden durante 40
minutos para coordinar la información
antes de su viaje a moscú que será
mañana los mandatarios hablaron sobre
los contactos que han hecho sus
gobiernos para intentar desescalar las
tensiones entre rusia y ucrania esto
llega luego de que el asesor de
seguridad de la casa blanca y ex alemán
afirmara que el kremlin podría invadir
territorio ucraniano cualquier día y que
esto provocaría un conflicto que dejaría
más de 50.000 víctimas sin embargo rusia
ha negado que quiera invadir invadir al
país
y este domingo la reina isabel segunda
cumple exactamente 70 años al frente de
la monarquía británica y es que el 6 de
febrero de 1952 comenzó su reinado luego
de que su padre jorge sexto falleciera
el mandato de la reina ha sido el más
largo de su historia en sus 95 años la
monarca sigue lidiando con polémicas y
acusaciones contra su familia ella por
su parte en la víspera de su aniversario
reconoció a camila como la próxima reina
consorte si carlos llega a ser el rey
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
esperen más informaciones minutos
[Música]